my husband and i and our two kids will
be going on a six-day trip with average
temperatures between mid-40s and high
70s
and in the past anytime we went on a
trip i actually used to share a carry-on
with our daughter and there are
undoubtedly many benefits to using a
carry-on you don't have to have your
baggage checked they're just so easily
portable and just depending on the kind
that you have
all the compartments can just make
organizing and arranging your items much
more easy
but now that our son has been born i
decided that the two of them will be
using the same carry-on and i will be
ditching the carry-on altogether and
using something else instead
[Music]
i will be using this diaper bag which
you probably wouldn't have guessed is a
diaper bag unless you have one yourself
i didn't have a designated travel bag so
i decided that
i would just repurpose the item that i
have rather than getting caught up in
consumerism and having the desire to
purchase more items
so this is it
so starting with the outside of the bag
in this side pocket here is where my
water bottle lives and i have the brand
yeti i am a big fan of yeti because my
husband works in construction and i'm a
home nurse we do not have microwaves or
refrigerators around so this is a very
reliable product for me that keeps our
things hot or cold
actually i've burned myself with
hours long coffee so you have to be
careful with that but it just fits nice
and snug in this pocket
it has hooks on the side where you can
attach things and on this side here i
actually have this is supposed to be a
pacifier bag which our kids don't use
but you can fit things like cables for
your phone or earpods and things like
that i won't be using it but it's
already here it's not bothering anybody
so it'll just hang out
and then on the front pocket here
is where i will keep my wallet my wallet
is kind of small but this pocket is
actually pretty large so it could
probably fit a small phone in here and
it's actually a cloth type material
which is very soft so i think it's made
for things like phones so that it won't
scratch or hurt your items that are a
little bit more gentle
i will also have a separate like
toiletry bag but i'll just kind of show
you here in this zipper i will keep kind
of the main toiletry items and on the
side slit here we have an ointment i
bomb i have eczema so when coconut oil
is not enough that is what i use
and of course we're in a pandemic so
hand sanitizer cannot fail
it also has this hook for keys
that i can just attach them and have
them easily accessible
and here it has like a little slit that
just keeps things together from falling
out i have basically a travel toothpaste
and our foldable
toothbrushes
i do not take my homemade toothpaste
when i go on trips because this is just
much easier
and this is actually my menstrual cup
and i'll show it to you it's very small
so i don't have to ever take pads or
tampons it's foldable it's by the brand
intima
i actually tried a luna cup before but
it doesn't fold like this one so i like
that it's just so easily transportable
and then on the side here we have just a
regular soap bar and this one is very
multi-purpose you can use it for your
hands body wash just
my husband uses it as a shampoo it is
just all around a very versatile product
and of course i have to put it in a case
because i'm not about to waste a
perfectly good bar of soap
mama is taking it back home
so that is it for this front zipper
pocket it's basically the main
toiletries that are in here and on the
very front it has a magnetic closure
which you could easily fit a passport
inside but being the mama that i am we
have children's books which why not
right
so it just snaps shut nice and easy
and on the top here is where i would put
my phone if i was using one but i'm
actually going to be going on a two-week
no tech challenge with no phone no
computer that type of stuff but because
i'm not going to be taking my phone this
time
instead i will be using it to place my
camera gear which is not really very
much it's just my
charging cord
an extra set of batteries
and then of course the camera that i'm
actually using to film right now so that
is it for that pocket
now on the side here because this is a
diaper bag is where it would normally
have the baby changing pad but i've
removed it and instead this is where i'm
going to be placing my planner and
because i'm not going to be having a
phone with me or a computer this is a
definite must i cannot go without this
thing
so it will just be nice and roomy in
this little pocket right here
which was kind of hard to zip one-handed
and i love that because it is a diaper
bag it is cushioned on the side so it's
cushioned on the arms and the back this
is actually a very comfortable bag to
travel in and it could easily fit a
laptop which would make it much more
comfortable to carry than a conventional
bag so sometimes i think you just have
to be creative with the things you
already have and repurpose them for
other uses
oh and of course i forgot i have to take
a pen because a planner without a pen is
very useless so it'll just live right in
here in this front pocket
all right so now let's show you what's
actually inside the bag and this zipper
closure actually opens up like a
suitcase which initially when i
purchased the bag i didn't really think
about it was just something that just
kind of happened but it actually serves
pretty well for this purpose as a travel
bag so on this front zipper is where i
usually place just dirty laundry which
sorry it was hard to open one-handed but
i have a little bag that i've repurposed
as my dirty laundry bag and this is a
tip that i have for you undoubtedly
having packing cubes will make it easier
to travel in i actually do have one but
if you have little bags like this or you
don't have the money to buy a packing
cube or you just don't want to buy some
you can reuse the things you already
have my husband has this husky bag that
was actually from some sort of a tool
that he purchased you could use this to
put your clothes inside to put your
dirty laundry so you don't have to have
a designated like packing cube or
purchase all of those designated travel
items if you don't want to or you don't
have the budget for them make use of the
things you already have even things like
a little pencil pouch or other little
baggies like that like this pencil pouch
here for example you could put little um
technology things in there like cords
and chargers
this bag that i have here is actually a
bottle bag which i can easily repurpose
because it's easily collapsible and even
like small little lunch totes you could
use to be able to organize your things
so be creative you don't have to go out
and purchase new items specifically for
travel this little bag for example is
actually where our wool balls were kept
in or actually arrived in but i use it
for my underwear and that's actually
where i keep it on a daily basis
and i did mention that i do have a
packing cube and this is the one that i
have had i've had this for years and i
can't necessarily say that i would
recommend this brand it's pretty worn
out i don't think that it's necessarily
sturdily made you can see that's kind of
tearing apart at the seams but you know
it's what i have i'm gonna make use of
it
[Music]
okay so let me show you what is actually
in this little travel case because
there's actually quite a bit that fits
in here the one thing if you can have
packing cubes they do make things much
more easy because you can see
how much it expanded and how much fits
in there so i have basically one
strapless black bra that i can use with
any kind of outfit my socks just fell
out
i have one little baggie that's where i
kept my underwear in and then i have
four tops which i roll them up because
that makes it so much easier to fit
inside the pouch
now as far as outfits go i would really
recommend that you have versatile items
that you can either dress up or dress
down and that you can actually layer so
for example i had a satin top that i had
just shown you and these are spaghetti
straps so it's going to be a little bit
warmer during the day but i can also
layer it if it gets cooler at night i
can wear this cardigan for example
and another tip as well is to wear these
types of things that are a little bit
bulkier a little bit warmer actually on
your person instead of packing them
inside so i'm actually going to be
wearing this cardigan on the way
and then if i get a little cooler i can
also layer on another piece which i have
just a basic black trench coat
so these types of items you can wear
on your person instead of packing inside
and it saves you so much room
as far as bottoms go i just don't really
feel that i need a whole lot of them so
i'm going to be wearing this pair of
blue jeans and i also have another pair
of black skinny jeans which i feel like
i can dress up or dress down if i wear
for example with my satin top and a
cardigan and it's just very versatile i
don't think that i really need a whole
lot a lot of places that you go you can
actually wash laundry if they get soiled
so
two is basically enough for me
and then i also have just a pair of
black or not black these are definitely
not black pair of basic shorts which are
very thin material so i could use them
to work out and to sleep in to swim in
they're just basically my all-purpose
shorts and because they are so small
they just fit so easily inside the
little pouch with very minimal space
and i actually fold my socks into little
rolls and i find that this saves me a
whole lot of room and heartache trying
to find them so let me show you how i
actually do it i place one sock over the
other so that one is higher than the
other
and then basically from there i roll
from toe to the ankle and then i just
wrap over the ankle portion and it makes
like a nice little taco
this saves a lot of room it looks much
more organized and it's gonna be easier
to find them as well and similar to the
socks i also think that it's important
on how you fold your shirts so i just
basically roll them up as well so that
they can save room this way you can
either store them upright or on the
sides and so let me just show you how
everything is packed up nice inside this
little pouch i was going to say neatly
but not really i just kind of stuffed it
in there
and i actually didn't show my socks in
there but i did go ahead and do it
afterwards they do definitely fit you
just kind of smush everything together
and it's nice and neat in one little
pouch
so that is all for my clothing except
for my shoes which we'll get to that in
a moment let me show you my toiletry bag
this is actually my makeup bag that i
use on a daily basis and it has
everything that i normally keep in here
plus a couple of things so let me just
dump it all out and show you what is in
here
one of the things that you will notice
is that i have one of each of these
items well except for the bobby pins and
one of the items that i've added is the
silicone earplugs because i don't know
about you but mama loves her sleep and
sometimes it can be hard to sleep in
unfamiliar environments inside this
little container is basically where i
keep my lotion or my version of a lotion
it is actually coconut oil inside here
which was hard to open one-handed so i'm
sorry i didn't show you but there's
coconut oil in there
and i probably could go without taking
my grooming scissors because i don't
think i will need them but they just
live inside here on a daily basis so eh
why not they'll just stay in there and
there's just one more item that i'm
going to be taking and it's just a pair
of flip-flops and i can use these to
lounge around in the house i actually
don't use flip-flops to go out in but i
use this little baggie that again i've
repurposed because i don't like to keep
my shoes touching other things and so
let me just show you how everything fits
inside so i have the flip-flops all of
my basically clothes and undergarments
and then my little pouch
so you can see that between all of these
things i mean this is my bag fully
packed i still have more room and so
maybe i could put in like a dress or a
skirt and sometimes though i like to
leave some empty space that way if i
were to go somewhere and i decide that i
wanted to purchase something i could
come back and have more room although i
don't see that likely usually i think
about my purchases before i make them
but this is it this is basically my bag
fully packed and ready to go
as you can see it is plenty roomy
and of course i did not forget about
shoes i will actually only be taking
this one pair of black booties and i
would recommend to you to find a pair of
shoes that is very versatile something
that you can dress up or dress down that
you find comfortable for me i find these
very comfortable because of their thick
sole but i love their versatility and
they can keep my feet warm during those
colder nights
so guys that is everything that i have
in my bag i hope that this video has
been helpful for you and if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel and i wish you guys
happy travels thank you for watching bye